[Music]
we are bursting with hometown spirit
this season celebrating hometowns all
across the country all season long
nicole moochie is about to show us
around her hometown of orlando florida
she's a mom and the creator of a website
dedicated to informing families on how
to have fun while learning about being
bilingual
watch this
welcome to orlando my name is nicole
muchi and i am the owner and content
creator of the multicultural maven which
is a lifestyle content blog i love
orlando because it's diversified there's
so much to do for families so i'm going
to take you on a little tour let's go
welcome to the town of celebration
this place is amazing it's located right
next to the disney area which is perfect
you can dine you can shop and it has an
amazing places that you and your family
can come to
this is the place you want to visit if
you want to get away from the hustle and
bustle of disney and have some great
restaurants to visit and places to stay
i'm here at lake eola park in the
downtown part of orlando we love coming
here to just hang out at the park check
out the swan little cars that they have
and bicycle on the lake and just explore
the nearby stuff like the public library
or just do some exercises with
homeschooling
hi guys and welcome to wikileaks state
park it's a great place to come get away
from the beach there's a lot of things
that you can do with your family like
newing and paddleboarding i've been
coming here since i was in high school
and we love that the springs are 75
degrees year round
it's a perfect place to be
drew thanks so much for coming on this
tour of orlando with me as you can see
orlando has so much for families to do
and people of all ages so i hope you can
come too see you soon
thanks nicole we love orlando and of
course i've been numerous times with my
daughters to go to none other than
disney world universal whatever theme
park will have us orlando is so
beautiful and so are you
[Music]
you